steel production is one of the most
polluting industries of the world
accounting for about seven percent of
the world's carbon emissions
now three swedish industrial companies
are joining forces for change
i'm here in lulio in northern sweden
close to the arctic circle
and this is where three industrial
giants have formed a partnership to set
up the first fossil free value chain to
produce green steel
and this site here
is
the entrance to hydrogen cave
which will be vital in this venture
so we're standing here in liblio
in this hydrogen storage
a key part of the venture is to develop
a hydrogen storage system so there will
be a steady supply of the fuel for the
production process
hydrogen
is used in the hybrid in the process
replacing coal when we turn iron ore
into iron um
by using hydrogen from fossil free
electricity instead of coal we remove
the source of emissions from this
process
you know just a couple of weeks ago we
were able to produce the first
fossa-free steel in the world and this
is now the next step in building a
completely fossa free value chain
together with our partners lkb and
watenfall a gas tank of about 100 cubic
meters
will be built inside this rock cabin to
store hydrogen if testing is successful
they could make it thousand times bigger
on an industrial scale
this is the product that you get when
you go from iron ore and reduce it
with hydrogen
and
instead of using coke and coal where you
get carbon dioxide you get water as a
boy product and that's when you get
sponge iron this is a raw material
then going to
ssab where you're supposed to to melt
this in an electric arc furnace
and from there
you you get steel that you
roll out
before you have
an end product
ssab has already struck deals with
mercedes-benz
and volvo group
who has recently launched the world's
first fossil-free vehicle
the vehicle behind me is a dumper to be
used in quarries or in mines
it is fully electric it is fully
autonomous and it's built upon fossil
free steel but i think that the beauty
now what we are learning with fossil
free steel is that from a manufacturing
perspective is no difference between the
traditional fossil based steel and
fossil free steel
if you look into a microscope the steel
is identical
transforming energy intensive industries
like steel production will be key to
combat global warming
especially as energy demand is expected
to continue to soar
[Music]
you